hi this is damon root for reason TV the
Supreme Court is a fast approaching the
end of its current term had major
decisions on affirmative action and
campaign finance reform but there are
several other major issues that have
flown under the radar that the courts
considering this term and here are three
cases I'm watching the first case is
called susan b anthony List V treehouse
now this case raises major questions
about both judicial review and First
Amendment essentially there's an Ohio
law that makes it a crime to speak
falsely about a political candidate this
law is enforced by state agency which is
staffed with political appointees the
susan b anthony List which is an
anti-abortion conservative group they
were hold before this state agency in
2010 based on a complaint filed by a
congressman who they criticized now
under the law any person in the state
can file one of these complaints and
susan b anthony List believes that the
law on its face violates the First
Amendment and gives the state agency way
too much power to police political
speech now the federal court said that
they did not suffer a concrete injury
and so therefore didn't have standing to
sue in effect the courts had said they
need to be convicted under this law it's
not enough that they were simply hauled
before the board in the crucial weeks
before an election so with the question
before the Supreme Court is whether
susan b anthony list gets its day in
court and then if it does get its day in
court it will move forward with a First
Amendment suit against the case i expect
the Supreme Court to a vote against Ohio
and to vote to let the susan b anthony
List have its day in court and and
moreover I I think the court should vote
against Ohio Susan the Anthony's should
be allowed to proceed with
constitutional challenge this law
clearly suppress their political speech
in the crucial weeks leading up to an
election
the next two cases are both on the same
issue but they're coming at it from
silly different angles now typically
when you're rested by the police whether
it's for a major or minor crime the
police have the right without a warrant
to search your pockets such a backpack
and also search the vicinity around
where you've been arrested so the
question here is when the police arrest
you do they get to search your cell
phone now the law enforcement argument
here is that the cell phone is the same
as a diary you might have in your
backpack or any of the other items that
traditionally the police would be
allowed to search when they've arrested
you without a warrant then the other
side points to the vast amount of
private information that the cell phone
stores and in effect a a cell phone
search without a warrant is the
modern-day equivalent of a general
warrant which is the very thing the
Fourth Amendment was put in the
Constitution added to the bill of rights
to protect us against so the court is
really i believe taken these two cases
to get that sort of a full briefing on
the whole scope of this issue so it's
very it's difficult to predict how these
two cases will turn out on the one hand
this is a court where we often see very
strong views on behalf of civil
liberties taking a protective
interpretation the Fourth Amendment but
the other hand this this question of new
technology gets the court into some
uncharted waters
this case also raises profound questions
of new technology essentially we've got
copyright law and how does it apply in
the digital age modern technology Aereo
is this company that that advertises
itself is what you can watch live TV
over the Internet but what they say is
that copyright laws don't apply to them
because they have this system of
antennas that's very individualized each
user essentially it's like the old
rabbit ears on your on your television
set in the 50's you can capture legally
the broadcast signal over the air and
watch it Aereo says they've got they've
got 10,000 dime-sized antennas those are
the same thing they're just providing
equipment to users the the people
challenging area ABC and other
broadcasters they take the opposite view
they say Aereo is violating copyright
law it has to pay the price needs to pay
royalties has essentially created this
workaround that is just thumbing its
nose at federal copyright law I tended
oral argument in this case and the
justices were plainly troubled by
arguments raised by both sides on the
one hand many members of the court
seemed to think that area really was
just trying to work its way around the
law on the other hand they were worried
that abc's arguments would imperil other
modern technologies if they prevailed
and the court was was openly grappling
with the way to balance these two
concerns and I'm not sure they figured
out yet how to do it
you
you